bonjour à tous je m'appelle christian je
suis le modérateur de la conférence de
presse nous disposons de 20 minutes avec
le premier ministre nous prendrons la
moitié des questions des journalistes
dans la salle et l'autre moitié
proviendra des journalistes au téléphone
nous aurons aussi du temps avec les
médecins et le ministre du clos et
monsieur le ministre
bon anniversaire en retard à vous la
parole
content d'être ici avec vous aujourd'hui
accompagné de la vice première ministre
en virtuel du ministre la santé jean
yves duclos a dit docteur news et la
docteure tam
depuis on a saisi
ce n'est pas ainsi que nous voulions
commencer l'année 2022 et je comprends
la frustration des gens je comprends que
les gens sont
fatigués et que la saison des fêtes a
été moins festif que d'habitude pour des
gens partout au pays
ça va bientôt faire deux ans que nous
vivons cette pandémie
il y a des moments plus intenses et des
moments moins intense mais je pense que
nous souhaitions plus nous souhaitions
tous être en meilleure position
aujourd'hui
de nombreuses régions du pays
sont confinés il y a eu
heureusement des mesures sanitaires et
en tant que parent je suis conscient du
fait que les infos sont de retour à
l'école en mode virtuel alors je
comprends tout à fait la frustration des
gens mais nous savons aussi comment
traverser cette période
tous les paliers de gouvernements
travaillent ensemble depuis des mois et
des années en fait maintenant afin de
vous donner ce qu'il vous faut au niveau
fédéral nous avons pu nous procurer des
vaccins nous avons administré des
vaccins à des niveaux record nous avons
pu fournir
des tests et nous avons fourni des
appuis financiers et nous continuerons
de vous accompagner à travers cette
situation nous vous avions promis que
nous prendrions soin de vous et c'est
exactement ce que nous faisons nous
voulons vous maintenir en sécurité nous
voulons tous les travailleurs de la
santé demeurent eux aussi en sécurité et
nous voulons revenir aux activités que
nous aimons le plus vite possible
cependant après deux ans de pandémie il
y a eu un changement par rapport aux
premiers mois
les canadiens eux mêmes ont changé
les canadiens savent ce qu'il faut faire
les canadiens savent comme un menhir
leurs proches en santé
vous savez aussi quoi faire pour éviter
un débordement dans les services de
soins de santé
vous savez que vous pouvez vous faire
vacciner dit que vous pouvez appuyer nos
travailleurs de la santé que vous pouvez
faire tout le nécessaire partout où vous
allez les canadiens ont démontré
les toffes ton s'ils sont faits et nous
allons continuer à nous serrer les
coudes pour traverser cette pandémie les
enfants sont de retour à l'école en mode
virtuel dans plusieurs régions
les pas et c'est de jongler
l'école et le travail
il y a des gens qui se font vacciner et
qui pose les bons gestes alors toutes
ces choses seront nécessaires au cours
des prochains mois
mais lorsque les vagues surgissent comme
la vague d'eau micro nous devons nous
serrer les coudes
et après quelques mois les choses
s'améliorent nous aurons un meilleur
printemps tant que nous continuons
chacun à faire le nécessaire
je remercie tous ceux qui ont posé les
bons gestes et tous ceux qui continuent
de faire des efforts il n'y a aucune
solution magique
personne ne veut être dans la situation
actuelle mais nous savons tous ce qu'il
faut faire pour traverser cette période
et je sais que les canadiens vont
continuer à le faire malgré leur
épuisement nous pouvons traverser cette
période ensemble
maintenant parlons des vaccins et des
doses de rappel nous avons maintenant
suffisamment de vaccins aux pays pour
tout le monde j'ai reçu ma dose de
rappel hier et ça fait partie des
efforts collectifs pour que pour écraser
la vague au micron et pour assurer
qu'elle nomme blood 6 pas notre système
de santé pensez au travers de la santé
qui ont travaillé pendant des mois dans
des situations difficiles
de se faire vacciner
si vous êtes là pour votre booster merci
suisse est en train de faire à vacciner
vos enfants c'est la bonne chose à faire
ici
vous approchez du moment où vous allez
choisir de faire votre première
vaccination
merci si jamais trop tard pour faire la
bonne chose
je peux vous assurer que les
travailleurs de la santé qui vont être
là pour vous donner votre premier vaccin
vont être très content de pouvoir vous
donner ce premier vaccin même
aujourd'hui même dans les semaines à
venir
nous savons ce que nous devons faire
pour passer à travers
we need you are nous devons chacun faire
notre part si vous n'avez pas encore été
vaccinés quelle que soit la raison
sachez qu'il y à un vaccin qui vous
attend vous pouvez aller à la pharmacie
ou à
centre de santé nous avons des vaccins
disponibles pour tous les canadiens
alors s'il vous plaît faites vous
vacciner c'est ainsi qu'on pourra
empêcher les débordements
notre système de santé et qu'on pourra
éviter les effets néfastes de l'aco vide
dans chez nos communautés et dans notre
système de santé nous continuons aussi
d'envoyer des tests rapides aux
provinces et aux territoires
nous avons livré un nombre record de
tests en décembre et nous allons
continuer en janvier
en 20 millions de tests rapides déjà
livré et on va continuer
on est là aussi en termes de
gouvernement fédéral pourrait aider à
les provinces et territoires qui sont
dans le plus de difficultés on finalise
le déploiement de 200 membres des forces
armées canadiennes à dans les cliniques
des vaccinations du québec et on va
continuer d'être là avec à les tests de
dépistage avec la vaccination avec les
traitements nécessaires
en même temps comme le gouvernement
fédéral a fait depuis le début on va
être là pour soutenir les travailleurs
et les entreprises
on continue d'avoir des mesures en place
pour vous appuyer si vous en avez besoin
je souligne particulièrement la
subvention salariale
qui est là pour vous permettre de garder
un lien à votre emploi même si le
travail et paulhan pour vous faire payer
pour pouvoir continuer à mettre
m l'épicerie
dans votre frigo
mais de savoir que vous gardez ce lien
avec le travail alors s'il vous plaît
cette subvention salariale utilisés par
les entreprises durement frappé avec de
l'aide aux loyers avec a désiré qu'aux
gens qui sont affectés nous sommes là
pour vous pourrez aider en plus les
provinces à pouvoir faire prendre les
bonnes décisions
les autorités de santé publique vont
savoir que oui s'ils ont besoin d'amener
des mesures additionnel de santé
publique on va être là pour les appuyer
on est là pour appuyer les citoyens
c'est comme ça qu'on passe à travers la
crise de santé mais c'est aussi comme ça
qu'on passe à travers la crise
économique en minimisant l'impact long
terme sur notre économie
workers
toujours appuyer les travailleurs
les pme nous avons des subventions
salariales du soutien au revenu c'est
difficile pour les entreprises alors
nous souhaitons que tous gardent leur
lien à l'emploi pour pouvoir remettre
des aliments sur la table dans le
contexte des restrictions sanitaires
actuelles nous savons que c'est la
meilleure façon passe à travers et de
relever ces défis c'est également la
meilleure façon de relever les défis
économiques
pour rebondir
à l'issue de cette vague alors merci à
tous et à toutes de faire votre part de
devenir ben nous allons continuer à nous
battre et de meilleurs jours s'en
viennent
nous cette année pour bâtir un canada
plus fort
de ce week cette semaine nous avons
signé une entente historique pour les
indemnisations des réformes pour les
services de soutien à l'enfance et à la
famille et ce qui a trait aux préceptes
de jardin pour trop longtemps les jeunes
enfants autochtones à risque ont été
retirés de leur communauté
et mis dans des situations où ils ont
perdu leur culture leur langue
ils ont fait face à de la maltraitance
on doit reconnaître notre responsabilité
collective
nous devons également mettre un terme à
cela l'avenir et
c'est en fait l'essence de cette entente
historique je remercie tous les partis
n'a les partenaires qui ont été à la
table au cours des dernières semaines
qui ont travaillé très fort nous avons
mis les enfants au centre de toutes nos
décisions de tout ce que nous faisons à
indemniser les enfants pour les
préjudices passés et afin de mettre un
terme ce préjudice à l'avenir
dans les différentes communautés
les dirigeants tokten merci
sénateur murray sinclair a été un
défenseur extraordinaire défenseur des
enfants
et les ministres les intervenants qui
ont travaillé dans aussi merci il reste
beaucoup à faire
nous avons signé ces ententes maintenant
on doit mettre en oeuvre les changements
on doit donc verser les indemnisations
doit veiller à transformer les services
d aide à l'enfance et à la famille dans
toutes les premières nations à l'échelle
du pays afin de briser ce ses plats qui
continue qui perdure et qui
font du tort aux enfants
c'est une période difficile également
puisque nous souvenons les victimes du
ps
5 2 et d'autres catastrophes aériennes
les familles donc qui
ont donc commémorer une autre saison
une autre d'un autre temps des fêtes
sans leurs membres cher leurs proches
sachez que nous continuons à nous battre
pour vous et nous sommes là pour vous
appuyer 1
dans le cadre de votre processus de
deuil nous demandons responsabilité et
justice 1
c'est la parole à notre me laisse la
santé jean yves duclos j'arrive
merci monsieur le premier ministre et
bonjour à toutes et à tous et permettez
moi tout d'abord de profiter de
l'occasion pour souhaiter une très bonne
et heureuse année à toutes celles et
tous ceux qui sont à l'écouté avec nous
aujourd'hui
malheureusement avec le variant au
micron qui se propage rapidement partout
au pays ce n'est pas le nouvel an que
nous envisagions il y à peine quelques
semaines malgré tout nous avons de
nombreuses raisons de rester positif et
optimiste par rapport à l'avenir
we have been chauds et longs nous avons
vécu beaucoup de choses au cours des
deux dernières années et je sais que les
canadiennes et les canadiens ressentent
les effets du stress et de la certitude
que la pandémie entraînent dans leur vie
soyons clairs janvier 2022 n'est pas
marcelle 2020 nous avons réalisé des
progrès majeurs et nous continuons
d'ajouter des ressources et des outils
pour contribuer à protéger et appuyer la
population canadienne
les efforts de planification de
réflexion à long terme que nous avons
fourni tôt pour tenir des vaccins elle
nous donne une plus forte meilleure
position pour affronter au micron l'an
passé nous avons déployé le plus vaste
programme de vaccination du sort du pays
près de 80% de la population canadienne
a été entièrement vacciner en 2021
d12 de rappel sont distribués partout au
pays et à ce jour plus de 7 millions
d'entre elles ont été administrées dans
l'ensemble du pays et pour terminer nous
protégeons nos enfants près de 40% des
enfants de 5 à 11 ans ont déjà reçu une
dose de vaccin ce mois ci nous nous
attendons à voir suffisamment de stock
au pays pour que tous les enfants
admissibles reçoivent leur deuxième dose
leurs deux doses en fait nous serions
dans une toute autre situation en ce
moment si nous n'avions pas un taux
d'accès nation si elle veut ni les
stocks de vaccins nécessaires pour
poursuivre
la de la vaccination maintenant c'est
simple c'est de vacciner les populations
non vaccinés de continuer d'accélérer
l'administration des lots de rappel est
de vacciner nos enfants
à ce sujet comme le premier ministre l'a
dit un peu plus tôt notre gouvernement a
annoncé lundi l'approbation de la
demande du gouvernement du québec depuis
hier les forces en est que les forces
armées canadiennes sont en train de
finaliser le déploiement de 200 membres
de leur personnel pour aider avec la
logistique liés à la vaccination
mon collègue le ministre de l'air et
nous représentants pour suivront
l'évolution évaluation de la situation
et adapteront l'appui au gouvernement du
québec au fur et à mesure de l'évolution
de la situation
on veut ne pas se fier aux et au cours
des dernières semaines tous les ordres
de gouvernement dû faire des choix
difficiles pour protéger la santé
publique et le système de soins de santé
le gouvernement fédéral a un rôle
important à jouer le mois dernier nous
avons mise en oeuvre de nouvelles
mesures frontalière pour gagner du temps
il ralentit sur l'arrivée du variant aux
migrants y compris l'avis donné au
canadien canadiens d'éviter les voyages
non essentiels notre gouvernement
élargit aussi temporairement
l'admissibilité de à plusieurs
programmes de soutien pour aider les
personnes touchées par les nouvelles
restrictions santé publique découlant de
la hausse des cadeaux mitron petit un
outil majeur pour nous aider comme
citoyens à réduire la propagation de la
coved 19 avant décembre 2021 notre
gouvernement avait distribué 80 5
millions de tests rapides aux provinces
et aux territoires
en décembre 2021
d'autres livraisons de tests rapides au
nombre de 35 millions ont été faites aux
provinces et aux territoires
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de confirmer
que 140 millions de tests rapides de
plus seront distribués dans les
provinces et territoires au cours du
mois de janvier à la demande de nos
partenaires provinciaux et territoriaux
ces stocks seront distribués en
proportion de la population de chaque
province et de chaque territoire ses 140
millions de tests équivalent à trois
fois les 35 millions de tests livré en
décembre dernier
rapide test aux provinces de béni les
tests rapides sont un outil important
pour nous aider les canadiens à réduire
la propagation de micron un vin le mois
décembre 2021 notre gouvernement elle
avait livré 85 millions de tests aux
provinces et territoires
en décembre 2021 seulement d'autres
stocks de 35 millions donc ont été
livrés à nos collègues dans les
provinces et territoires aujourd'hui
j'ai le plaisir de confirmer que 140
millions de testeurs à pied deux
supplémentaires seront distribués dans
les provinces et territoires au cours du
mois de janvier à la demande de nos
collègues provinciaux et territoriaux
ces stocks seront distribués en fonction
du nombre d'habitants
les
ce2 et ce2 rapide en descente
janvier représente trois fois donc les
déjà délivré les 35 millions alors les
inventions et les livraisons sont en
cours et nous vous tiendrons au courant
donc à l'échelle du canada tous les
ordres du du gouvernement de
gouvernement font lors de leur mieux
pour
contribuer à ralentir la propagation du
virus nouvion vivent une période
difficile mais elle ne durera pas nous
avons les outils nécessaires pour nous
sortir de cette pandémie il faut
continuer à exercer notre
prudence santé et celle des autres en
suivant les objectifs des responsables
de la santé publique
continuons de prendre soin les uns des
autres et de garder espoir c'est ainsi
que nous allons pouvoir passer ensemble
à travers ces nouveaux défis de la
nouvelle année je dirais qu'il n'ya pas
de pays mieux préparés que le canada
pour passer à travers cette nouvelle
vague de la pandémie
ensemble merci et je me tourne
maintenant avec plaisir vers la ministre
des finances et la vice-première
ministre madame christiane fendt
merci beaucoup je n'y ai et bonjour tout
le monde
agm en ligne avril bonjour tout le monde
notre gouvernement comprend
afin de gagner la bataille contre covic
nous devons disposer des bons outils on
a besoin de vaccin de tests rapides et
de médicaments thérapeutiques que nous
avons besoin d'avoir des mesures en
place pour soutenir les personnes les
entreprises toit du économique afin de
passer de composer avec les restrictions
et les confinements nous disposons des
outils notre gouvernement a passé
l'automne à mettre en place ces outils à
faire des investissements pour nous
préparer pour cet hiver difficile en
décembre avant les fêtes nous avons
publié une mise en avec une mise à jour
économique prévoyant des investissements
notamment l'achat de 180 millions de
textos rapide et un 2 2 milliards
d'investissements dans les médicaments
thérapeutiques pour soutenir nos efforts
collectifs pour en terminer avec l'aco
vig et
donc
composer avec au micro ayant annoncé le
lancement du programme d' aides ciblées
pour les canadiens et les entreprises
canadiennes incluant une provision pour
une renouvellement des subventions
salariales et pour le loyer on casse du
continent ces programmes sont entrées en
vigueur en décembre avec l'adoption du
projet de loi chase de plus avec la
progression du variant au micro ondes et
les nouvelles restrictions mises en
place dans les provinces à travers le
pays nous avons décidé d'élargir
temporairement la définition du
confinement pour les à ce qu'aucune
travailleurs et aucune entreprise ne
tombe entre les mailles du filet nous
avons créé ces mesures pour permettre
aux autorités de santé publique de
prendre les décisions parfois difficiles
qui s'imposent en sachant que le
gouvernement fédéral sera là pour
soutenir les travailleurs les pme les
autres employeurs dans leur communauté
et notre soutien depuis le début a été
un brin nabeul en effet le gouvernement
fédéral a fourni oui dollars sur chaque
tranche de 10 dollars dépensés pour
lutter contre la colique 19 au canada et
pour soutenir les canadiens et
canadiennes
inrix récemment comme nous le savons
tous trop bien
les régions du pays ont annoncé de
nouvelles restrictions de nouvelles
mesures de confinement ces restrictions
ont une incidence sur l'emploi et sur
les entreprises
j'aimerais aujourd'hui rassurer les
canadiens et leur rappeler que le
gouvernement fédéral a veillé à ce que
le soutien économique soient disponibles
en cas de besoin
la semaine dernière les demandes ont
ouvert pour la prestation de confinement
pour les travailleurs et donc si vous
êtes un travailleur dans une région du
pays qui est en confinement ou qui fait
l'objet de restrictions c'est de 50% et
si vous avez perdu 50 % de votre revenu
en résultat des restrictions appliquées
vous pourriez être admissible à recevoir
300 $ par semaine et vous pouvez
maintenant faire une demande en ligne
par l'agencé du revenu du canada nous
savons également que les entreprises
notamment les petites entreprises ont
besoin de soutien c'est pourquoi nous
avons mis en place un programme de
confinement locales dont qui
fournira donc du soutien des subventions
jusqu'à 75% vos employeurs dont qui ont
dû réduire la capacité de leur
entreprise principale par 50 % ont plus
et je rappelle aux entreprises que nous
avons abaissé le seuil de revenus de
cars 2 40% à
25%
et nous avons également du soutien aux
loyers à 25% donc piqué disponible pour
les entreprises et qui font l'objet d'un
confinement total start up des seconds
dès le début de cette pandémie nous
avons compris
que d'avoir un emploi est important pour
le bien être des canadiens s'est appuyé
salariaux il s'est appuyé pour les
locataires font en sorte que les gens
peuvent maintenir lié avec leur
employeur ça veut dire que les familles
et les particuliers ainsi que les
entreprises peuvent demeurer robuste
c'est ainsi qu'on peut maintenir une
économie saine
les appuis
seront disponibles du 19 décembre au 12
février vis d'autres pertes liées à la
pandémie par l'entremise de programmes
de relance pour le tourisme et l'accueil
et de grands tours et lens pour les
entreprises et plus durement touchés
je tiens à rappeler que cette aide
financée par les contribuables et offert
entreprises pour leur permettre de se
tenir leurs travailleurs est passé à
travers la pandémie
toute entreprise publique prestataires
de la subvention salariale qui choisit
de verser à ses cadres supérieurs une
rémunération bonifié par rapport à
l'année 2010 neuf devra rembourser
l'aide précieux par ailleurs les
entreprises qui versent des dividendes
tout en réservant la subvention salle
avel deviendront
inadmissible au programme
entre gouvernement prend au sérieux la
tâche de gérer prudemment les finances
publiques nous nous attendons à ce que
les entreprises canadiennes admissibles
cesse preuve de respect à l'égard de ses
programmes d aide et qu'ils démentent
cette aide seulement si seals on en est
loin
de best way la meilleure façon de mettre
terme à cette pandémie et les meilleures
politiques économiques
sont les politiques sanitaires robustes
tels que le premier ministre et jean
yves viennent de le lire la meilleure
chose que nous pouvons tous faire c'est
de nous faire vacciner et d'obtenir une
ode aux deux rappels
j'aimerais également rappeler à tous les
canadiens que
quand cette période difficile en tant
que pays
nous avons démontré notre résilience
la semaine dernière des économistes à
côté la performance économique du canada
en deuxième place dans le palmarès
mondial
nous n'avons pas perdu autant d'emplois
que prévu au cours de la pandémie et le
canada a le deuxième taux de mortalité
le plus faible lié à la queue vide dans
le g 7 ans nous entrés dans et en
travaillant ensemble nous avons pu
maintenir une économie robuste et nous
avons pu sauver des vies je sais que
c'est une période un peu effrayante et
une période frustrante c'est une période
difficile mais j'aimerais tout de même
rassurer les canadiens nous avons les
outils nécessaires pour traverser cette
période nous savons quoi faire en tant
que pays et nous sommes résilient nous
l'avons démontré ici au pays mais aussi
à l'étranger
pendant presque deux ans maintenant
nous vivons une période sans précédent
mais nous avons relevé le défi ensemble
je sais qu'aucun d'entre nous ne voulait
vivre cette vague au micro mais nous
devons la traversée ensemble et je sais
que si nous continuons à collaborer nous
pourrons la traversée ensemble la parole
aux anneaux collègues les journalistes
pour que nous poser les questions
bonjour à tous alors le premier ministre
sera seulement avec nous pendant 20
minutes nous allons commencer avec les
questions des journalistes dans la salle
et ensuite les journalistes ne pourront
pas posé de question de suivi tom perry
de cilicie allez-y question monsieur le
premier ministre
et monsieur du cloud vous avez dit qu'il
y aurait 140 ou 150 millions de tests
rapides livre hic alors quel est le
chiffre
réel est aussi pensez vous que vous
serez en mesure d'acheter tous et est
aussi au québec nous voyons que les gens
se ruent sur les tests est-ce que vous
pensez que nous pourrons réduire cette
ruée ou améliorer la distribution au
niveau des provinces réponse il y aura
140 millions de tests livré en janvier
alors j'ai dit qu'il y aurait 140
millions de tests et ses 4 x 35 140
millions de tests avaient aussi dire que
c'est un test rapide par semaine par
personne au canada en janvier
woodson
nous savons tous que
les tests rapides font partie de la
solution pour traverser la pandémie au
cours de la dernière année nous avons vu
que certains endroits comme la nouvelle
écosse utilisent les tests rapides à un
niveau très élevé et le gréement fédéral
augmente aussi la distribution des tests
rapides aux provinces et territoires et
c'est aux provinces et territoires de
déterminer comment ils vont les
distribuer c'est un autre outil dans
notre arsenal
mais avec la vitesse à laquelle au
micron se propage dans la communauté et
dans le pays nous pensons qu'il est
juste de fournir des tests rapides et de
les distribuer
parce que nous voyons l'évolution du
nombre des cas partout au pays mais
comme vous l'avez mentionné tom la
distribution des tests rapides elles
principalement effectués par les
provinces et nous essayons d'obtenir
autant que possible et de les distribuer
gratuitement
et ce sont ensuite les provinces qui
seront chargés de les distribuer à leurs
populations nous avons aussi des tests
réservés aux populations vulnérables
mais la vaste majorité des tests seront
distribués directement par les provinces
et territoires
savons que des tests de dépistage rapide
font partie de la solution partie des
outils que nous avons pour s'attaquer à
cette vague au micro il ya des provinces
qui depuis un deux puis plus qu'un homme
utilise le dépistage rapide de façon
beaucoup plus présent je pense à à la
nouvelle écosse par exemple mais
certainement
de s'assurer en temps gouvernement
fédéral que il ya assez de tests de
dépistage rapide qui se rendent aux
provinces et territoires
c'est notre responsabilité comme venise
la santé a dit nous nous à nous sommes
en train d'en procurer des millions des
dizaines des centaines de millions mais
a mais ce sera aux provinces et aux
territoires de développer à la mer façon
de distribuer sa aux citoyens
chinois bonjour que si on nouvelles de
radio-canada bonjour bonne année vous
deux
en français en anglais s'il vous plaît
on a des problèmes ce qui limite
l'accessibilité aux tests pcr donc des
gens qui sont très positifs à la coved
qui ne se feront pas détecté et des gens
qui se font des tests antigènes à la
maison qui vont peut-être avoir la
colline qui vont pas se déclarer est ce
que vous êtes est ce que ça vous
inquiète et à quel point ça vous
inquiète d'avoir une vague invisible de
la colline
et je vais répondre brièvement et je
vais éviter si vous le permettez
madame docteur tam à fournir plus de
précision d'un point de vue scientifique
parce que comme elle le dira
probablement il ya d'autres outils dont
les provinces et territoires peuvent se
servir pour combler le vide
d'information qu'effectivement on
observe au canada en fonction de la
rareté non seulement des des équipements
mais surtout du personnel pour
administrer les tests pcr à travers le
pays encre est un enjeu important aussi
que les provinces et territoires font le
maximum d'efforts qu'elle peut faire
étant donné que la la les procédures
autour de ces tests est un des nombreux
enjeux auxquels les provinces et
territoires font face il faut accélérer
la vaccination les dozos rappelle entre
autres parce que on sait que c'est
d'autres appels sont nécessaires pour
ramener la protection vaccinale à un
niveau
suffisant est satisfaisant et aussi
évidemment une crise dans beaucoup de
dents droit au canada en matière de de
capacité des soins d d d d hôpitaux
d'accepter de soigner les nombreuses
personnes qui ont besoin de soins avec
le variant au micro mais sur les
questions de quelles informations
additionnelles on pourrait aller
chercher je m'en étais premier
territoire pour aller chercher je me
tourner rapidement vers la docteur
docteur camille
temps qu'il faut
merci pour la question
au canada
nous avons suffisamment de tests pour
surveiller la propagation du virus
etc va rien
et tests moléculaires
ne sont pas nécessairement envoyer à nos
laboratoires il y à des systèmes en
place pour recenser les cas et les tests
rapides
pendant la semaine qui a précédé le 1er
janvier un mille des millions de tests
de laboratoire ont été effectués alors
si on essaie de suivre la propagation de
ce virus nous pouvons suivre les
tendances
les provinces ne dépiste pas tous les
cas mais il y a quand même des tests qui
sont effectuées et nous serions au
courant si jamais une vague se
propageait dans une communauté en
particulier
nous pouvons
avertir les
unités de santé locales pour leur dire
si la propagation de varier en
particulier a lieu dans leur communauté
beaucoup différents outils qu'on est en
train d'utiliser on va on va utiliser
tous ces différents outils pour
s'assurer d'avoir une idée
le plus exact possible de la réalité de
micron à travers le pays juste parce
qu'on utilise différents outils ça veut
pas dire que une vague est visible au
contraire on une très bonne idée de
l'étendue de micron
l'important par contre c'est de pouvoir
s'assurer d'être là pour les gens qui en
ont besoin pour les travailleurs de la
santé d'assurer qu'il ya pas de deux
de surcharge dans nos hôpitaux et c'est
avec six ressources lors que nous allons
maximiser nos efforts
pour nous question bonjour monsieur le
premier ministre
vous avez parlé des enfants qui sont
retournés à l'école en mode virtuel et
la frustration ressentie par la
population
qu'avez vous à dire aux parents à qui on
a répété que la fermeture des écoles
serait le tout dernier recours et
qu'avez vous à dire aux gens qui
critiquent les mesures sanitaires qui
n'ont pas été prises pour prévenir cette
situation
réponse nous avons dépensé 63 milliards
de dollars en appui financier au système
de la santé nous avons aussi fourni des
appuis aux provinces nous continuerons
de faire les hosties cement nécessaires
pour aider les gens à traverser cette
crise mais je comprends la frustration
ressentie par les parents nous avons
tous été
étonnés au cours de la fin de semaine
d'apprendre que les écoles allait
reprendre en mode virtuel et tous les
parrains et c'est de s'adapter
tout en respectant les règles sanitaires
en tant que premier ministre en tant que
gouvernement mon rôle est de fournir des
vaccins et des tests rapides de protéger
nos frontières de fournir des appuis
pour le revenu et les salaires d'appuyer
les travailleurs et de faire en sorte
que les provinces disposent des outils
nécessaires
pour aider leurs citoyens pour aider
leurs habitants alors nous voulons faire
tout notre possible pour aider tous les
paliers de gouvernement question
monsieur le ministre il ya quand même
une proportion élevée de canadiens qui
refusent de se faire vacciner et qui
refuse d'accepter
l'obligation vaccinale en france de
nouvelles mesures ont été imposées et le
président macron à dick souhaitait
emmerder les gens qui résistent à la
vaccination alors qu'avez vous à dire à
ces personnes non vaccinées qui
surchargent lot centre de soins
intensifs réponse nous savons que les
canadiens ont mis l'épaule à la roue ils
ont fait le nécessaire pour protéger
leurs proches pour protéger les
travailleurs de la santé et oui c'est
c'est important nous faisons pas une
passe et des meilleurs pays au monde en
matière de prévention de la queue vide
donc nous faisons la bonne chose et ce
n'est pas seulement
il n'est pas seulement question des
travers de la santé ou du gouvernement
qui est frustré il y a aussi des
canadiens qui refuse encore de se faire
vacciner
lorsque les gens voient leur chirurgie
ou leurs traitements oncologiques
repoussée parce que des lits sont
occupés par des nous vacciner ils sont
frustrés au rythme
lorsqu'on se retrouve
un confinement
lorsqu'on subit les restrictions
sanitaires étant donné le risque posé
par les personnes non vaccinées et les
gens sont frustrés ils sont en colère
nous avons mis en place différentes
mesures pour encourager % pour éduquer
pour sensibiliser pour
convaincre les gens et la raclée et que
ce n'est jamais trop tard pour faire la
bonne chose n'est jamais trop tard pour
obtenir sa première dose de vaccin et je
peux vous dire que les professionnels la
santé de première ligne qui est vous
donnera votre première dose de vaccin et
même au match aller 2022
ces professionnels sont extrêmement
heureux de vos administrés cette
première dose de vaccin même aujourd'hui
par ceux qui le préfèrent
vous faire cette injection de la
conviction que de vous un tube est en
soins intensifs et il faut continuer à
faire la bonne chose il faut faire
ce que font la majorité des canadiens se
protéger pour que nous puissions donc
retourner à ce qu'on aime faire question
drink pris pendant la campagne vous vous
avez dit que sunwing et est un chef de
file ils ont reçu des subventions mais à
la lumière de la vidéo qui montre un que
à
vieillir partie une fête à bord de ses
vols est ce que votre gouvernement va
demander
des remboursements d'un swing et qu'en
est il de ses passagers lorsqu'ils
reviennent au canada réponse je peux
vous assurer que ce transport canada
prend cette situation au sérieux il y
aura une enquête un qui fera la lumière
sur ce qui s'est passé dans ce vol sur
cette situation donc
les canadiens qui ont vu ces vidéos
sont frustrés
nous savons à quel point c'est laid à
quel point nous avons travaillé fort
pour se protéger nous avons fait des
sacrifices
on apporter nos masques on s'est fait
vacciner on a fait tout ce qu'il
voudrait faire donc c'est vraiment une
claque au visage de voir ce genre de
personne se mettra à risques et mettre
les autres à risque m également le
personnel
de l'avion à risque donc c'est
absolument irresponsable alors je peux
vous dire que transports canada prend
cette situation au sérieux et nous avons
sur une enquête de suivi
que transports canada prend très au
sérieux la situation avec ce vol nolisé
c'est inacceptable
que des gens soient en train de mettre à
risque pas juste les autres passagers
pour juste les travailleurs des lignes
aériennes
mais leurs concitoyens au retour en plus
quand les gens sont en train de faire
les sacrifices
et jean centrant en ont réduit leurs
contacts pendant le temps des fêtes on
peut au vu des êtres chers la vaste
majorité des gens à travers ce pays
savent qu'il faut faire des sacrifices
pour se protéger les uns les autres
et quand tu ne gagnes 200 dessins qui
décide de partir comme des ostrogoths en
vacances
c'est propre
c'est extrêmement frustrant c'est des
morales démoralisation démoralisant et
je peux vous dire que transports canada
et le gouvernement du canada prend ça
très au sérieux on va faire des suivis
sur comment ça s'est passé
à présent question
problème
ne semble pas être la quantité de
vaccins aux deux testeurs rapide
disponible mais plutôt la capacité des
provinces et territoires à les
distribuer
le
gouvernement est également responsable
des premières nations et
quelle mesure prenez vous pour veiller à
ce que les communautés des premières
nations les communautés éloignées a
accès à ces tests et aux vaccins réponse
depuis le début de la pandémie
en tant que gouvernement fédéral
nous avons accordé une grande attention
aux vulnérabilités présentes et par les
premières nations à l'échelle du pays
la vue dans le cadre des pandémies
passées à shannon notamment à quel point
les communautés autochtones sont venir à
bleau pandémie alors c'est pourquoi
depuis le mois de mars 2000
nous avons donc mis l'accent sur
le fait de s'assurer du soutien ou
communauté autochtone à celle du pays
que ce soit la vaccination
avec le maderna dans les communautés
dont ce qui éloigne et ensuite il ya eu
des mesures de dépistage et de
déstockage et 10 ont été prises on a
offert des soutiens supplémentaires pour
les travailleurs de première ligne du
continueront à être là pour veiller à la
veille au grain et veiller à ce que ce
qui est suffisamment de fournitures dans
ces communautés puisque nous
reconnaissons les vulnérabilités et en
donner
étant donné les infrastructures mois
robustes à face trop sûr de santé
notamment dans ces communautés
ministre du clos le 1er nice a bien
résumé la situation
j'ai une collaboration avec la ministre
ado et ministre miller qui travaille
avec la santé publique pour veiller à ce
que comme l'a dit le premier ministre
les premiers peuples les premières
nations du canada pour les raisons
mentionnées rapidement donc sont bien
équipées soutenu une façon appropriée
étant donné les circulait circonstances
dans lequel il se trouve comme l'a dit
le premier ministre nos efforts ont été
couronnés de succès alors des premières
vagues on nous avons veillé à ce qu'il y
ait des campagnes de vaccination hâtives
nous les avons soutenus continuerons de
le faire nous avons
du temps pour deux questions téléphone
opérateurs
la première café en 2000 à une crête la
presse la parole est à vous
bonjour j'aimerais savoir concernant les
tests rapides
elles que étant donnée la longue
garantie qui seront disponibles en
janvier est ce que vous pensez que les
provinces qui ne le font pas devrait
permettre la vente libre en pharmacie
de deux choses rapidement là-dessus
effectivement les livraisons sont
considérables je mentionnais ya quelques
instants le 140 millions de doses de
polo de tests rapides en janvier de 140
millions c'est déjà quatre fois la
livraison de 35 millions en décembre
entre ça et les 35 millions décembre
c'était cinq fois plus que la moyenne
des tests qui avaient été demandées par
les provinces au cours des mois
antérieurs donc après vingt fois plus en
janvier que ce que traditionnellement
les provinces et territoires avait
demandé au cours de 2021 la deuxième
chose c'est que c'était sont fournis
gratuitement par le gouvernement
canadien aux provinces et aux
territoires
et comme le premier ministre le disais
il ya un instant on a tout entière
confiance que les provinces et
territoires vont utiliser ces tests de
manière la plus efficace et la plus
équitable possible
efficace évidemment parce que ces
ressources vont continuer d'être rares
les tests rapides sur la scène mondiale
sont en très grande demande le canada se
débrouille très bien pour aller chercher
autant de tests aussi rapidement mais
déteste ce sont des des tests lors en
quantité mais évidemment limitées et il
faut que ces tests soient fournis aux
gens qui en ont le plus besoin on sait
que depuis quelques semaines c'est ce
qui se passe la plupart des provinces et
territoires livre ces tests non
seulement rien rapidement mais aussi en
fonction des besoins des gens qu'ils ont
la chance de servir
dernière question pour le premier
ministre qu'il parte
question
vous annoncer aujourd'hui 140 millions
de tests rapides olives aux provinces et
territoires êtes vous préoccupé par
l'utilisation qu'en font les provinces
et territoires on sait que
sont utilisés différentes façons à
nantes en anteryon les a distribuées
dans wells et bio et aux étudiants alors
est ce que vous croyez que on les
utilise correctement pour freiner la
propagation du virus une réponse merci
pour votre question brian
il ya eu plusieurs disons version au
cours des dernières années
en fait lorsqu'on parle d'une province
ou d'une autre qui répond à un aspect ou
une autre de la pandémie pour
reconnaître dans ce contexte
les différentes régions du pays qui
composent avec des 60 différentes en
fait nous sommes une fédération
la prestation de services de santé un
combo province et ils le décideront donc
de la façon dont ils doivent la façon
de répondre aux besoins de leurs
populations sur conseil de leur autorité
sanitaire notre responsabilité en tant
que gouvernement fédéral et de veiller à
ce qu il y ait assez de tests rapides
assez de vaccins insuffisamment de
traitement est suffisamment de soutien
au revenu suffisamment de contrôles
frontaliers
s'agit là des compétences fédérales
donc
nous travaillons avec les provinces et
j'ose espérer que les progresse donc
pour en partager des enseignements quant
à ce qui fonctionne bien et s'attend
également à ce que les provinces et
territoires soit là pour distribuer ces
tests rapides que nous fournissons
en quantité
afin de passer à travers cette vague de
micron
merci au 1er mai du canada de s'être
joint à ne s'être joint à nous donc un
grand merci au premier ministre d'être
là nous allons poursuivre la conférence
de presse ce pendant 15 minutes ce que
nous faisons quand je vais rester au
téléphone
opérateurs première question des
téléphones de barils prouvés de voir
apparaître vous
bonjour j'aimerais savoir ce que vous
pensez des annonces des gouvernements
provinciaux comme le gouvernement du
québec qui a réduit la période
d'isolement lors ce contexte positif à
la coke 2009 de 10 jours à cinq jours
est-ce que de votre point de vue
d'autorité de santé fédéral s'est
approprié vous n'êtes pas en danger
je vais rapidement retourné le docteur
tam et le dr nu sur les tests rapides de
j'aimerais juste précisé que pour le
québec car en proportion de la
population c'est au tour de 31,5
millions sur les 140 millions g j'ai pu
échanger avec le ministre du buisson
matin pour lui fournir cette information
parce que on sait la queue que le québec
a demandé
ddd livraison de tests plus importante
cours des derniers jours et c'est donc
avec plaisir que j'ai pu lui confirmé
cette information ce matin pour la
question je vais éviter la docteure
table où le docteur docteur new
donc les bons jours ces deux recrues
peut-être ai-je pu commencer à répondre
à votre question aussi dire que tu es
morte aussi toujours ajouter quelque
chose c'était l'enjeu actuel ans on
continue à discuter avec nos homologues
des provinces et territoires parce que
on sait c'est quoi la situation à
l'heure actuelle le verrions micron est
partout donc il y en a dix cas partout
et toujours le début de la santé
publique c'est de minimiser réduire la
morbidité mortalité mais aussi à avoir
le comédien aussi minimisé comme les
perturbations dans notre société on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
perturbations répulsion maintenant pour
aller un des secteurs que les travers
essentiel aussi dans un système de soins
de santé donc on en a aussi à des bonnes
discussions avec les six lycées aux
états unis et aussi qu'il y aura
peut-être une équilibre entre les
objectifs de la santé publique mais
aussi pour la comédie le fonctionnement
de la société donc ça c'est l'enjeu
actuel à nos connaissances a continué à
évoluer avec avec les données probantes
et à l'heure actuelle on sait que c'est
c'est un défi trouver un équilibre entre
ce qu est ce qu on score avec nos
connaissances de la période de comédie
contagiosité pour quelqu'un qui est
contaminée infectés avec le virus et
aussi pour le fonctionnement de la
société donc je pense que c'est vraiment
un enjeu axway pour les provinces et
territoires et comme comme toujours les
provinces et territoires
ils connaissent les autorités
connaissent leur situation leur contexte
et s'est trouvée nez qu'il est bon pour
nous autant continuer nos discussions
avec nos homologues des provinces et
territoires
et je peux vous dire que en fin de
compte c'est aussi une question de
peut-être une tolérance et ceux des
chaleurs * gestion de crise parce que tu
as qu une différence entre dire oui si
on veut être vraiment conservateur a
isolé les les cas confirmés pour dix
jours oui c'est toujours là
idéal mais c'est pas possible avec la
situation qui existait maintenant dans
est-ce que cinq joueurs et c'est
acceptable oui à 5 jours peut-être que
la plupart des personnes infectées
peut-être que un peu communicative et et
isolé à la maison mais c'est ce soir
c'est sûr qu'ils aient un certain
pourcentage qui peuvent être encore
inspectées et peut-être
vont sortir de leur isolement
d'encaisser quelque chose on continue à
discuter
pour trouver peut-être un équilibre avec
le seuil de tolérance
merci
du tuyau est ce qu'on a des détails sur
le mes tests rapides vont elles être
livrés en boîtes de 20 et savez vous
s'il ya un calendrier d'une audience dit
qui est prévu pour progresser millions
de tonnes aux provinces la fonction
billy semaine de janvier est flamand si
vous acceptez une responsabilité
quelconque dans le manque de tests
rapides à la pénurie qu'on n'est plus
dans les
pharmacies
merci beaucoup à trois questions
différentes première question sur les
boîtes il y a un assez grand nombre de
types de tests rapides qui ont été
demandés et qui sont donc livrés aux
provinces et aux territoires je n'ai pas
le détail avec moi mais c'est une
maîtrise assez compliqué où chacune des
provinces
traditionnellement
bon je sélectionne un certain nombre de
différentes boîtes évidemment on a une
contrainte à l'échelle nationale donc à
la faim les des demandes des provinces
sont on en tient compte mais il faut
s'assurer que tout le monde soit traité
équitablement donc certain nombre de
tests différentes
différentes boîtes qui sont livrés
depuis depuis déjà presque plus qu'un an
et qui ça va continuer comme ça au cours
des prochaines semaines pour les détails
exacts sur combien de tests combien de
bois de combien de cepsa faudrait voir
avec les fonctionnaires sur la question
des échéanciers b déjà ces semaines ya
un nombre assez important de tests qui
sont en train d'être livrés c'est
plusieurs millions juste pour le québec
cette semaine si et mais étant donné la
fragilité des chaînes
d'approvisionnement on préfère confirmé
la livraison des tests le nom de
livraison quand on a effectivement la
confirmation que c'est ce qui se passe
sur le terrain et dernière chose pense
que personne
ne cherche à blâmer personne je lui ai
déjà dit et d'autres l'ont aussi dit au
cours des dernières semaines les
provinces et territoires avant décembre
2021 faisait face à un très grand nombre
de défis et la priorité des tests
rapides n'étaient peut-être pas à
l'époque que celle qui est qui et que
les provinces et territoires de devait
privilégier ça changeait beaucoup à
partir du début du mois de décembre
on est passé d'une moyenne de 7 millions
de tests par moi qui t'ai demandé à 35
millions livré en décembre 1940 millions
livré en janvier parce que la demande
des provinces et des territoires a
considérablement augmenté en quelques
semaines donc on s'ajuste comme on peut
le voir très rapidement en collaboration
avec toutes les provinces et toutes les
tous les territoires et je voudrais je
dirais que là la bonne foi et la bonne
collaboration sont vraiment très
présente à la fois dans les discussions
et dans les actions
une question de ce téléphone avant de
retourner à la salle est jamais demandé
à nos à éviter de donner des pistes de
hédé de donner des réponses concises
en
question
merci d'accepter nos questions ma
question s'adresse à la ministre fuir
end au sujet des prestations
de nombreuses entreprises au pays
face à la pénurie de main d'oeuvre alors
on ne leur dit pas de se confiner ou
de fermer leur entreprise
mais on voit plutôt que les travailleurs
tombent malades ou leurs enfants tombent
malades et ils sont incapables de se
présenter au travail yaté des programmes
d'appui salariaux pour ses scénarios là
où est ce que certaines entreprises
seront forcés à fermer leurs portes même
s'ils n'ont pas reçu d'ordre de la part
de santé publique pour fermer leurs
portes
réponse merci pour la question stéphanie
il y à trois niveaux d'appuis disponible
aux entreprises
et j'aimerais mettre l'accent sur le
fait que ces mesures sont disponibles
les subventions salariales et les
subventions pour le loyer seront
décaissés de façon rétroactive
alors le portail est disponible en ligne
et vous pouvez aller faire une demande
il y à l'appui en cas de confinement
alors si vous êtes entièrement confinée
ou s'il ya des restrictions qui diminue
votre clientèle de 50% ou plus vous êtes
donc admissibles à la subvention de 25 %
pour le loyer
alors ça c'est le des appuis disponibles
il y a aussi l'appui pour le secteur
touristique
et il y a les appuis pour les
entreprises les plus durement touchés
aussi c'est de dernier appuie ne
requiert pas peur confinement ni des
restrictions
stéphanie les entreprises que vous avez
mentionné qu'ils ne sont pas assujettis
à des confinement ou à des mesures de
restriction et qui ne font pas partie du
domaine du tourisme
pour ces entreprises si elles veulent
être admissible il faudrait qu'elle soit
une entreprise parmi les plus durement
touchés
question
à quoi question pour les docteurs la
food and drug administration aux états
unis a approuvé les dose de rappel pour
les enfants de 12 à 17 ans qu'en est il
du canada comme pouvons nous attendre à
une approbation pareil
réponse ici tri ce terme je ne sais pas
si le ministre aimait répondre à cette
question ou s'il aimerait que j'y
réponde
réponse du ministre duclos
la dr dame nous signale que cette
décision revient à l'organe
réglementaire de santé canada et de l'
agence de la santé publique du canada et
évidemment ils sont indépendants de mon
bureau qui est un bureau politique mais
nous vous donnons des réponses plus
précises sous peu
la docteure tamazout j'aimerais aussi
ajouté que nous allons consulter le
comité consultatif national sur
l'immunisation nous sommes en train
d'examiner les données qui ont été
fournies par le fabricant et c'est ainsi
que le processus d'approbation
fonctionne habituellement
alors les choses peuvent être légèrement
différente au canada et aux états unis
mais c'est sûr qu'on vous reviendra avec
une réponse une fois qu'on aura pris une
décision évidemment nous voulons que les
doses le régime de doses
de base soient administrés et nous
voulons que les doses de rappel soit
administrée aussi surtout pour les
personnes les plus à risque
question
dr termes que pensez vous du fait que
les provinces comme l'ontario sont ont
réduit la période d'isolement à cinq
jours et qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
formation fournie aux contacts
rapprochés est ce que c'est une bonne
chose qu'en pensez vous
réponse
dr nous avait aussi donné une réponse à
cette question
nous communiquons avec tous les
administrateurs un chef de la santé
publique de partout au pays et nous
continuons toujours à nous familiariser
avec le variant au micron nous apprenons
à connaître sa période d'incubation nous
sommes entrés de
d'étudier toutes ces caractéristiques
scientifique et d'éliminer certaines
incertitudes la meilleure approche
c'est de maintenir une période
d'isolement plus longue mais nous savons
aussi que pour que la société continue
de fonctionner et pour que les systèmes
de santé continuent d'opérer il faut
faire des ajustements
alors en ce moment en raison du volume
élevé de cas les provinces ne font plus
de gestion individuelle des cas c'est
impossible pour le système sanitaire
alors il se concentre plutôt sur les
lieux les plus à risque et il
il étudie et trace les contacts dans ces
cas là
mais pour le reste de la population
si vous êtes un cas positif ou si vous
avez un contact il y a des règles
cinq jours d'isolement est ce que ça
suffit et bien si vous voulez prendre
des mesures
avec toutes les précautions possibles on
pourrait proposer de garder une période
d'isolement plus longue mais nous
comprenons aussi que les provinces
doivent trouver l'équilibré entre la
santé et le maintien de leur structure
de base leur structure essentielle il
faut continuer le port du masque il faut
continuer à le porter adéquatement et il
faut continuer à le faire même si on est
plus en isolement question de tempérer
de cbc
avez-vous
et préoccupations au sujet de la
capacité des tests rapides à détecter le
varia au micro réponse
il y a encore des données qui entrent
mais
la difficulté avec ce virus c'est
que les gens peuvent rapidement être
effectuée après leur exposition et que
la situation évolue rapidement
si on a un test négatif le matin ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on n'aura pas de test
négatif
plus tard au cours de la journée
alors il faut faire des tests rapides
fréquents
selon
nos statuts nos situations individuelles
question
avez vous une mise à jour au sujet de la
définition
de des personnes clés pleinement
vacciner est ce qu'on va bientôt inclure
les doutes de rappel pour être considéré
pleinement vacciner réponse
pas pour le moment au niveau fédéral
nous savons que la plupart
en fait
nous savons que les doses de rappel ne
sont pas disponibles partout au monde
mais nous reviendrons à cette décision
plus tard
nous savons que les programmes de
dodo te rappelles sont en cours un peu
partout au pays
est la chose la plus importante c'est
d'avoir
les deux doses pour nous protéger et une
dose de rappel pour augmenter la
protection mais les vaccins qui sont
disponibles dans le monde en ce moment
ne suffisent pas pour réduire le taux
d'infection est lié ovarien ou micron
mais la protection est quand même
rehaussé si on
obtient une dose de rappel
mais du côté ministériel rien n'a changé
je remercie l'inde espère ministre la
docteure tarn et
et monsieur duclos et c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui
[Musique]